mes chers collègues nous nous retrouvons
ce matin avec un ordre du jour consacré
à l'audition de Madame marine Jeant
directrice générale de de l'agence de de
biomédecine mais avant de commencer
cette audition si vous me le permettez
je voudrais rendre hommage à un homme
politiqueun de mes prédécesseurs qui
nous a quitté il y a quelques jours il
s'agit de de Jean-Marie R ancien
sénateur de de la Moselle qui fut membre
de l'office de l'OPEX dès sa création en
1983 qui était son président d'octobre
86 à juillet 88 et date à laquelle il
devient ministre du Commerce extérieur
puis des post et des télécommunications
comme on disait à l'époque secteur dont
il était un un spécialiste reconnu et et
vraiment en avance sur son temps donc il
a eu cette parenthèse gouvernementale de
de 4 ans mais il fut sénateur sans
discontinue de 1974 à 2001 soit pendant
quand même près d'un quart de siècle et
son mandat de maire de M F encore plus
long puisqu'il était maire de 1971 à
2008 c'est-à-dire 37 ans alors à l'opeex
il avait été l'auteur du du 2uxème
rapport de de l'office du
vraiment tout premier sur les
conséquences de l'accident de la
centrale nucléaire de Tchernobyl et la
sûreté et la sécurité des installations
nucléaires rapport qui avait eu en dter
un un fort impact et par son
exhaustivité son sérieux sa hauteur de
vue donner dès l'origine une grande
crédibilité à à l'opexte et je vais vous
livrer la principale recommandation de
ce rapport qui était la création je cite
d'une agence nationale de la sécurité et
de l'information nucléaire indépendante
des pouvoirs publics et des exploitants
d'installation nucléaire autrement dit
la future ASN et donc on est en
1900 87 voilà donc 20 ans avant la
création effective de laasn cher
Jean-Luc ça alimente notre réflexion sur
le futur projet de loi voilà donc ça
tout ça nous montre à quel point
l'Office a été vraiment précurseur et et
ça doit poursuivre sa mission
d'évaluation et de contrôle de la sûreté
de la sécurité nucléaire notamment comme
l'avait bien très bien anticipé nos
prédécesseurs et en particulier donc
Jean-Marie roche qui nous a quitté il y
a quelques
jours je reviens à l'ordre du jour donc
que je vous ai annoncé Madame la
Directrice générale nous sommes très
heureux de vous accueillir ce matin à
l'office cela fait presque un an que
vous êtes à la tête de cette agence de
la biomédecine pour ceux des collègues
qui ne vous connaissent pas je précisis
que vous Z une formation de de médecin
de santé publique que vous avez été en
poste à la Direction de la Sécurité
sociale que vous avez exercé des des
fonctions à l' ns et la CCMSA et que
vous avez ensuite été directrice des
risques professionnels à la CNAM et
délégué puis délégué interministériel à
la prévention et à la lutte contre la
pauvreté avant donc de rejoindre
l'agence de la biomédecine en prenant
vos fonction le le 1er février dernier
donc il y aura bientôt un an vous avez
affiché plusieurs priorités la mise en
œuvre des des nouvelles disposition de
la loi bioéthique de
2021 la relance aussi des activités de
greffe et d'assistance médicale à la
procréation l'AMP en en acronyme anglais
nous souhaitons donc aujourd'hui vous
entendre sur les activités de l'agence
mais aussi et surtout sur les évolutions
récentes des connaissances et des
techniques dans les domaines relevants
des lois de de bioéthique justement
c'est une vous avez une des missions que
la loi donne à l'agence en spécifiant
que cette veille sur les loi de
bithtique doit être effectuée au profit
du gouvernement et du Parlement à
travers l'Office c'est l'office donc qui
re principal interl locuteur sur ses
aspects scientifiques et techniques
l'Office ayant lui aussi pour mission
d'évaluer l'application des lois de de
bioéthique al la dernière audition de
l'agence de bioéthique remonte à mars
2018 précisément lorsque nos deux
collègues préparaient le rapport de
l'ofix qui évaluait l'application de la
précédente loi de bioéthique et donc ça
fait un petit moment presque 6 ans que
nous n'avons pas fait le point sur ces
questions de greffe de Don d'organ d'AMP
de recherche de médecine génétique
autant de sujets que nous dont nous nous
réjouissons de pouvoir faire sur le
faire le point avec vous ce matin je
vous laisse donc la parole pour
présenter tout tous ces sujets tous les
sujets qui qui vous qui vous que vous
jugerez utile et nous passerons ensuite
à un petit débat avec les parlementaires
qui sont présents et qui arriveront
peut-être avec un peu de retard cont
tenu des conditions de circulation lié à
la condition climatique de cette
nuit merci monsieur le Président
Mesdames Messieurs les les députés et
sénateurs je suis très honorée de
pouvoir faire un état des lieux de de
notre action devant vous ce matin donc
je vais d'abord très rapidement vous
présenter un petit diaporama qui vous
présente un peu l'avancement des plans
des trois plans ministériels que nous
avons dont nous avons la charge parce
que c'est a pas mal de graphiques et je
pense que ce sera plus explicite aussi
pour vous donner les évolutions et puis
après je vous propose que on pourra
balayer aussi le question
que vous nous aviez envoyé pour avec un
certain nombre de questions je vous
enverrai de toute façon dans la journée
une réponse écrite qui vous verrez qui
est assez copieuse donc on va essayer
d'aller à l'essentiel aussi pour vous
donner les principaux points mais il y
aura tous les détails et les chiffres je
je le dis aussi pour vos collaborateurs
par écrit après alors l'agence vous la
connaissez bien est-ce que ça marche
voilà oui c'était donc un établissement
public qui est qui relève du ministère
de la Santé qui a été créé maintenant il
y a bientôt 20 ans et qui a
effectivement dans ces domaines
d'activité tous les aspects de greffe
d'organes de greffe de cellules souche
et matopoétique et puis de tout ce qui
est AMP et médecine génétique donc on a
ça je vais passer très rapidement je
voudrais donc on a effectivement trois
plans sur chacun des champs qui qui ont
été annoncés donc en 2022 ils sont tous
sur la même temporalité donc on est
bientôt à mi enfin on est à mi-parcours
donc c'est le moment aussi de faire un
peu un état des lieux de d'avancement
alors on va commencer par les organes
tissus ça ce c ça est assez important
j'aimerais rester 2 minutes dessus c'est
juste pour vous montrer l'évolution de
la liste nationale d'attente de greffe
en gros il y a plus de 20000 personnes
qui sont inscrites sur la liste en
général c'est plutôt 10000 personnes qui
sont potentiellement greffable parce
qu'il y a des gens qui sont en
contre-indication donc à un moment vous
savez vous avez une infection ou autre
vous pouvez pas être greffé donc en gros
on est plutôt sur sur 10000 personnes et
vous avez le nombre de greffes qui sit
aux alentours de 5 1000 et donc voilà
tout ce que je voudrais vous alerter
c'est vous dire en gros c'est un chiffre
assez simple il y a 23 nouvelles
inscriptions par jour sur la liste
d'attente de greffe il y a 2,3 personnes
qui décèdent sur la liste tous les jours
faute de greffons disponible et on a à
peu près 15 Greff par jour donc ça veut
dire qu'il y a presque six personnes
chaque jour qui augmente
structurellement la liste d'attente de
greffe d'organes c'est qu'on est quand
même assez loin c'est pour vous donner
un peu une ampleur des besoins de santé
publique sur ce sujet-là même si on
progress même si on augmente parce que
si on regarde juste le nombre de greffe
on jeis vous alleer voir on est dans les
couloirs de croissance qu'on s'est fixé
mais en terme de réponse au besoins de
santé public je pense que c'est
important que vous ayez ça en tête pour
pour voilà positionner même si aussi on
réduit le nombre de décès sur sur les et
c'est pour ça qu' aussi dans la vu
l'objectif de votre de votre office tout
ce qui va permettre les nouvelles
technologies nouvelles thérapeutiqu qui
vont éviter l'évolution vers
l'insuffisance rénale chronique ce que
nous on va essayer maintenant de plus en
plus de se positionner dans une logique
préventive de parcours de soins pour
éviter l'arrivée ou le besoin dans la
greffe ça permet aussi c'est on a des
des il y a des des des pistes hein mais
c'est vrai que T tous ces éléments là
ces nouvelles thérapeutiques sont quand
même des des avancées parce qu'on on
n'est pas sûr d'arriver à répondre à
toutes ces greffes tous ces besoins de
greffe de manière très
matérielle alors d'autant plus que nous
avons là je vous mets rapidement vous
savez qu'on a une grosse hétérogénéité
on a besoin pas de greffe sans
prélèvement d'organes et on a une grosse
hétérogénéité dans le prélèvement
d'organes en France euh en particulier
en lien avec l'opposition vous savez
qu'on est tous présumés d'honneur mais
le jour comme si il faut qu'on en ait
parlé à sa famille c'est pour ça qu'on
fait toutes nos campagnes maintenant en
disant parlez-en parce que on demande
toujours la bord l'accord des proches
quand même au moment de de prélever ce
qui est quand même la moindre des choses
vu les situations un peu dramatiques et
quand les gens ne on se trouve que les
les les Français sont 80 % favorables au
don d'organe mais ils n'en ont parlé que
dans 50 % des cas à leur famille ce qui
fait que au moment dramatique et on ne
sait jamais quand est-ce que ça va
arriver les familles ne savent pas et
dans le doute ils s'abstiennent et ce
qui est très inquiétant est ce que vous
allez voir mais je vais je vais revenir
c'est c'est la slide qui doit être juste
après voilà c'est qu'on a un taux
d'opposition qui augmente en ce moment
depuis 2023 on était à à 36 % alors que
pendant structurellement pendant des
années on était à 30 %. euh on ne sait
pas exactement les déterminants de ce
taux d'opposition on sait que c'est
quand même un peu corrélé à la colère
sociale on va dire que on voit que on a
des pics d'inscription sur le registre
de refus donc qui est le au moment ben
de de du passe sanitaire au moment de la
réforme des retraites voilà donc on voit
qu'il y a quand même un un lien entre là
et avec des lettres parce que là les
gens le font de leur vivant donc ils
expriment leur motivation donc c'est une
toute petite partie mais il y a
probablement ça il y a aussi des
facteurs religieux c'est pour ça qu'on
va travailler aussi avec toutes les
obédiences religieuses pour pouvoir
essayer de parce qu'il y a aucune
opposition dans aucune des trois grandes
religions monothéistes pour
pouvoir se s'opposer à à la au
préslement d'organe mais encore faut-il
que cette information
arrive aux familles concernées donc on
est quand même dans un un sujet voilà
qui qui vient bloquer ça veut dire que
plus d'un d'une personne sur trois qui
pourrait être prélevable n'est pas
prélevé un pourcentage sur toi là pour
bien comprendre le c'est le nombre de
personnes de de personnes de de donneur
potentiel à qui on a demandé les
familles on regarde en fait il y a en
gros 36 % des familles de donneurs au
moment du au moment du prélèvement qui
qui s'oppose et et s'ajoute et je
reviens juste en arrière à l'évolution
aussi du prélèvement dans les dans les
hôpitaux je ne vous cache pas
qu'actuellement la situation assez
dramatique des hôpitaux joue parce que
il faut que ces personnes pour être que
les organes puissent être prélevés il
faut qu'ils soi en réanimation et on a
des des problèmes d'accès soit en
réanimation soit au bloc parce qu'on a
et vous voyez qu'il y a des des régions
vous voyez au Vern renal par exemple ça
a été assez catastrophique il y a eu pas
mal de problèmes aux hcell cette année
et du coup ils sont ils ont diminué
énormément leur prélévement quand
l'Île-de-France c'est un petit peu
réveillé parce qu'on on est allit
beaucoup stimuler la PHP pour qu'il
puisse répondre que c'est quand même un
potentiel de donneur
important alors euh donc ça c'est
l'hétérogénité donc je vous montre les
régions où il y a le plus deutau
d'opposition c'est pas inintéressant
c'est les domes sans surprise avec vu le
le le le climat social et l'île-de-fance
et également PACA donc c'est et haut de
France donc en général c'est les
endroits où il y a aussi des climats de
tension sociale
notre activité de grève je vous le
disais elle est en train de de
redémarrer voyz on a bien progressé en
2023 on est à plus 2,5 % donc on vous
verrez on est dans les découloirs de
croissance on n'est pas encore
complètement revenu à la à la moyenne
vous voyez d'avant covid qui voilà qui
était plus importante mais qui avait
commencé à décroître avant le covid hein
donc il y a des c'est pas que le covid
qui est responsable de la chute il y a
eu aussi des des problèmes aussi au sein
des hôpitaux et la structuration des
filières de de l'organisation des soins
un tout petit mot sur sur les greffes
rénales parce que c'est la majeure
partie de nos greffes euh il y a pour
vous donner le le le le le la
répartition voyez on a à peu près 70 %
qui sont issus de donneurs décédés et on
a 16 % de donneurs vivants c'est un des
objectifs du Plan greffe vous savez on
sait que les greffes fait à partir de
donneur vivant fonctionnent mieux parce
qu'elles sont programmées et avec un
temps d'eschimie froide très faible et
puis on on est en train d'augmenter les
donneurs d'acm3 dont on vous a je sais
pas si ça vous parle mais en fait en
gros sur les les donneurs à cœur arrêtés
et c'était un de nos objectifs aussi du
plan Greff on est en train de de
d'augmenter significativement la part
des des greffons issu de de ce type de
prélèvement donc c'est un des objectifs
qui avait été dans dans vos
questionnaires sur le le l'échec de du
du plan précédent c'était aussi
développer le prélèvement multisource et
on est en train de voilà de de d'activer
les choses et notamment sur le don
vivant on a mis en place on a on vient
de sortir des nouvelles recommandations
on a mis en place un référent national
qui fait le tour de tous les centres
hospitaliers qui sont en très en de ça
des objectifs pour aller rencontrer les
directions rencontrer les équipes pour
essayer de lever les freins et on va
essayer aussi d'avancer avec le don
croisé mais vous savez que la loi de
bithtique avait permis l'augmentation de
l'apparillement des paires mais en fait
c'est pour l'instant on est encore on n
pas on a pas réussi à démarrer parce
qu'il y a très peu de il faut qu'on ait
beaucoup de propositions donc croiser
voilà pour que ça fonctionne et pour
l'instant d'où l'intérêt aussi d'aller
stimuler les équipes parce que plus on
aura de de d'équipes qui proposent des
des patient au don croisé plus on pourra
faire d'apparillement de
paire un un mot juste pour vous
rappeleer que ça c'est un sujet aussi
important auquel je suis très sensible
vu mes précédentes fonctions c'est les
inégalités d'accès à la greffe je vous
mets juste C slide qui c'est en gros là
vous avez la répartition l'accès à la
greffe depuis le début de la dialyse
selon les régions et vous voyez que il y
a une différence énorme entre l'ouest de
la France et des Outremers par exemple
ces inégalités territoriales sont le
reflet de d'inégalité à la fois
d'incidence des pathologies qui sont
voilà il y a beaucoup plus de de
prévention de de de moins de prévention
et plus de surpois de diabète dans
certaines régions de France et aussi des
inégalités de d'accès aux soins et de
pratique médical donc ça c'est un des
sujets sur lequels on on va on est en
train de se pencher à l'agence pour
aussi aller sensibiliser les
professionnels à C à cette question là
parce que il y a il y a il y a
clairement aussi des pratiques médicales
qui viennent un peu en double peine sur
pour certains patients euh sur les les
grands les grands axes du plan je vais
vous je vais surtout vous que vous
donner les rép ce qu'on a proposé on
pour je vous dis on a un gros sujet sur
la partie prélèvement d'organe qu'il
faut augmenter parce que si le nombre de
Greff est dépendant du nombre de de
greffants disponibles on voulait mettre
en place des IPA c'est pour l'instant ça
n'est pas encore acté par le ministère
c'est plus compliqué que en fait voilà
il y a la bonne c'est pas forcément la
bonne idée on se demande si on va pas
proposer aussi des des solutions
alternatives un peu de d'incitation euh
de de valorisation du prélèvement
financière pour les établissements comme
sur le modèle espagnol qui avait bien
fonctionné donc on va voir voilà c'est
une discussion mais comme je vous cache
pas qu'on a un peu de turnover dans
notre ministre ministères en ce moment
c'est pas facile d'arriver à construire
donc c'était on était en train de
construire ça donc on espère reprendre
avec la nouvelle équipe et puis on a
donc tout un travail aussi sur les
coordinations hospitalières qu'on
accompagne et qu'on forme on fait des
audits on a développé prélèvement
multisources je vous en ai parlé on a
aussi essayé de on a un plan qui a été
financé donc c'est pas c'est pas rien
donc on a permis on est en train de
réviser aussi les forfaits pour les
hôpitaux parce que là aussi c'est très
important aussi de reconnaître
l'investissement en temps et en en homme
de de de des établissements on crée des
indicateurs de performance on est en
train de ça c'est aussi important de de
l'ordonn et puis voilà on a surtout mis
quelque chose qui est en place qui est
assez novateur en terme de santé
publique c'est qu'on a un comité de
suivi qui associe toutes les parties
prenantes avec donc les professionnels
les associations de patients l'assurance
maladie les AR le ministère et on fait
des réunions deux fois par an avec tout
le monde où on expose avec des réunions
préparatoires où chacun peut exposer en
fait c'est c'est pas simple à gérer on
est parce que il y a évidemment pas mal
de heur et de d'opposition mais ça
permet aussi de partager les difficultés
d'essayer de trouver des solutions de
faire remonter des bonnes des idées
locales et et nous on trouve que c'est
vraiment très intéressant et on a doublé
ça d'un pilotage régional maintenant on
a impliqué les ARS qui ont des référents
parce qu'on il y a beaucoup des blocages
qu'on a sont des problèmes
d'organisation territoriale des soins et
donc sans les ARS on ne peut pas avancer
sur sur ces sujets-là euh donc ça c'est
les objectifs quantifiés ce que je vous
disis on est ça se voit peut-être pas
très bien mais il y a la petite étoile
rouge c'est l'endroit où on est donc on
est vous voyez on avait créer un peu des
couloirs de croissance ça c'est qui
aussi donnait un peu des objectifs donc
on avait commencé un peu progressivement
qu'on sortait de crise vous voyez
qu'après les courbes deviennent de plus
en plus hautes et ambitieuses pour
l'instant on est dans les couloirs de
croissance vous voyez que si si on reste
au même niveau l'année prochaine on y
sera plus donc il y a on a un vrai enjeu
en 2024 d'arriver à à transformer
l'essai ce qui n'est pas hyper facile vu
le l'état des des établissements
hospitaliers avec des des blocs a des
des des CHU qui ont un tiers de leurs
bloc qui sont fermés hein leur tir de Ra
qui sont fermés donc sans sans bloc sans
RA vous faites pas de greffe donc c'est
les voilà le financement j'en ai parlé
je voudrais vous parler rapidement des
des cellules souches donc ça c'est les
greves de moelle ça c'est pour vous
donner l'activité de de greffe de moile
osseuse que de greffe de moelle de C
sououche qu'on qui est en France de
depuis en évolution depuis quelques
années en gros vous voyez en en vert
c'est la partie on va dire qui qui est
gérée par des c'est des donneurs non
apparentés c'est les les donneurs qu'on
va chercher à l'étranger ou ou sur un
registre français et en bleu c'est les
les les donneurs apparentés donc c'est
les greffes intrafamiliales donc vous
voyez qu'en gros on est à peu près à
2000 greffes par an euh et ça c'est à
peu près moitié enfin c'est un peu plus
sur les donneurs non apparenté 55 en
gros qui sont 55 % qui viennent de
donneur non apparentés ce qui est ça je
vous ai mis la répartition par par
région aussi vous voyez que c'est assez
hétérogène aussi l'activité c'est c'est
là aussi c'est pas qu'un sujet de de de
prévalence de pathologie il y a aussi un
sujet accès au soin là c'est juste une
une slide pour vous montrer que
l'évolution vous avez ça je sais pas si
c'est très lisible mais en gros la la
barre plus importante vous savez qu'on
peut avoir plusieurs sources de de
greffe de moelle soit c'est les cellules
souches périphériques dans le sang qu'on
qu'on récupère C ferise soit c'est par
un prélèvement sur l'ociliaac soit c'est
sur les unités de sangl interre et en
fait ce qui est très intéressant de voir
c'est depuis quelques années c'est la
même chose au niveau mondial maintenant
la très grande prédominance c'est les
cellules souches périphériques c'est
qu'on ne fait plus beaucoup de
prélèvements sur la l'ocelac qui était
douloureux qui nécessitait pour le
donneur une hospitalisation c'est cette
donc ça permet à des donneurs quand vous
êtes inscrit c'est c'est moins
douloureux c'est que maintenant 80 % des
des prélèvements qui son se font de
cette
façonlà euh là c'est une activité de
notre registre parce que vous savez que
nous on a donc à la fois on inscrit les
personnes qui ont sont en attente de
greffe de moelle on essaie de leur
trouver le meilleur greffon apparente
apparenté soit dans le notre registre
national soit à l'étranger il faut que
vous sachiez que 90 % des personnes qui
sont greffées en France des patients
greffés en France ont un greffon qui
viennent de l'étranger donc c'est on est
on est interfacé avec 75 registres et en
fait à chaque fois on choisit le
meilleur voilà la meilleure
compatibilité qui est qui qui qui donc
en gros je vous dis on est à peu près à
2000 personnes de qui sont inscrites qui
là en 2023 et par contre on a aussi on
gère nous on a un registre maintenant de
qui a à peu près 400000 personnes on a
aussi des on est interrogé pour par pour
des patients étrangers et donc ce qui
est intéressant c'est de voir qu'on a on
a progressé on a à peu près on était à 6
% je vous dis des des personnes qui
avant étaient greffé en France qui était
issu d'un donneur national on est passé
à 10 % on a un objectif de 25 en fin de
grve donc je suis pas sûr qu'on arrivera
à 25 % dans 2 ans et demi mais enfin on
est en train de progresser mais par
contre ce qui est très intéressant ça
c'est un un bon qu'on a en 2023 c'est
qu'on a eu une explosion de la demande
de notre registre pour des patients
internationaux on est à plus 71 % de
demande euh parce qu'en fait on a un
registre de qualité nous on a fait aussi
le choix de diversif au lieu parce que
vous pouvez les nous on a 400000
personnes les Allemands par exemple ont
un registre avec 9 millions de personnes
et en fait c'est tous les mêmes
phénotypes les mêmes génotypes donc
c'est beaucoup moins c'est c'est c'est
moins varié nous on a la chance c'est
aussi l'histoire de la République
française on a aussi une population
extrêmement varié et on on on on joue
sur cette diversification parce que ce
qui fait queon a un registre de qualité
pour pour arriver à à répondre aussi à
des besoins
internationaux et et ça c'est pour vous
donner un peu la la répartition vous
savez qu'on peut s'inscrire jusqu'au
jusqu'au 36e anniversaire si je me
trompe pas sur le registre donc vous
voyez qu'on est on a un objectif de
masculinisation et de rajonnissement de
notre registre parce que vous êtes
inscrit jusqu'à 36 ans et après vous
pouvez être prélevé jusqu'à 60 donc vous
voyez qu'on a quand même des des des
encore une part importante de personnes
âgées mais on a quand même un bon un
rajonissement non non négligeable de de
de jeunes par que les greffons sont de
meilleure qualité quand vous greffez des
des des personnes prélevez des personnes
jeunes et des hommes quel que soit parce
que les les femmes on avec les
grossesses même non non connu une greffe
une moelle qui s'immunise et donc c'est
de moins bonne qualité donc à 70 % les
les greffeurs veulent demandent plutôt
au privilégi des donneurs
masculins voilà donc là aussi juste
quelques mots sur vous dire qu'on a des
des tensions he hospitalières sur le
sujet on a un accès difficile à la cite
affireise hein donc c'est pour pouvoir
trier le sang euh donc qui qui du coup
restreint l'activité on a des d'ailleurs
des une compétition avec l'activité de
carticell pour ceux qui connaissent donc
qui sont les travail donc on on modifie
les cellules d'une personne pour traiter
un cancer pour les faire rendre tueuse
du cancer de la personne ce qui est une
innovation extraordinaire mais qui du
coup c'est ça c'est les mêmes ressources
pour les greffes de moelle et donc comme
elles n'ont pas augmenté ben c'est des
patients au détriment des autres donc
c'est un sujet on a aussi un besoin
notamment des diff en en pédiatrie
pardon et dans le parcours postgff il y
a des places qui manquent aussi pour le
suivi en en soin de suite donc c'est
voilà ça c'est un des éléments plus
techniques et donc on essaie
effectivement je vous laisserai ces
slides mais de de d'essayer d'améliorer
de soutenir ces équipes pour arriver à à
leur trouver des des solutions et
surtout de d'attirer l'attention des
directionshospitalières sur ces sujets
un peu particuliers parce que c'est
quand même des des des des gens qui
gèent ces greffes c'est des des
techniciens très forts qui sont pas
remplaçabl facilement donc il faut aussi
faire attention
alors voilà euh sur nos les les la M qui
est un sujet comme vous le savez qui a
donc la loi de bioéthique avait a ouvert
donc au couple de femmes et aux femmes
non mariées a étendu aussi a permis
l'autoconservation des gamettes à des
fins non médicales et a permis aussi
l'accès aux origines pour les enfants
issus d'un don de gamett alors là on on
est face à une révolution he enfin on va
vous le dire comme ça ça a été une
explosion de la demande ce qu'on avait
qui n'avait pas tout à fait été anticipé
au moment du vote de la loi on a plus de
30000 demandes en gros en 2 ans sur le
sur ces nouveaux publics qui sont et
c'est une demande qui ne faiblit pas
donc la demande en gros a été multipliée
par 8 par rapport à la à laamp au
parcours AMP avant de de couple
hétérosexuel donc c'est un ça a mis en
tension très forte les centres euh là
vous voyez je vous ai mis aussi une fois
que vous avez fait les demandes après il
y a les premières consultations et après
il y a les premières tentatives donc
tous ces chiffres sont corrélé hein on
est on est en train de mais vous voyez
que c'est assez massif comme
augmentation euh on a des âges ça
c'était un sujet qui nous concernait de
voir en gros pour les les les les femmes
non mariées c'est plutôt des femmes qui
arrivent à la limite après après 35 ans
voyez 50 enfin en gros 70 % c'est après
35 ans donc je c'est quand elles n'ont
pas pu faire un enfant dans d'autres
dans une condition plus classique alors
que mais on a quand même 7 % de jeunes
femmes qui ont moins de 29 ans donc
c'est pas ça aussi on s'attendait pas à
ce que des femmes aussi jeunes et
viennent
recourir à la MP et par contre sur les
couples de femmes c'est plutôt c'est
plus distribué c'est c'est sur des les
âges classiques en fait de de
procréation comme les couples hétéos euh
ce qui faut que vous sachiez que
maintenant les nouveaux publics donc les
couples de femmes et les femmes seules
représentent 80 % de la liste d'attente
sur les parcours d'AMP donc c'est c'est
un point très très important
euh et on a des délais qui sont à peu
près de voilà de de de 18 mois enfin de
de 16 mois pardon avec des grosses
variations selon les
centres sachant que ça c'est hors
parcours à l'étranger donc il y a il est
possible aussi que des moi j'ai pas les
délais pour les gens qui vont à
l'étranger mais on sait que ça ça
forcément comme il y a des quand
importants comme je vous ai dit pour les
femmes seules en plus c'est à des âges
elles sont aux âges limites donc tous
les mois compent donc si elles ont des
gros délai au moment où si elle commence
à aller à 36 ans consulter voilà il il y
a aussi des on sait que
jusqu'à la fertilité chute brutalement
après 38 ans
euh donc ça c'est les dons de vos site
sachez que les donneurs de vosite
continuent de progresser donc on a par
ce qu'on a besoin aussi mais on en a
toujours pas assez hein on est en
tension majeure he sur les les dons de
vos site euh même si leur délai aussi là
là vous voyez on est sur des délais
d'attente quand vous avez besoin d'un
don de vos site sur presque 2 ans hein
sur c'est un sujet et encore il y a une
restriction d'inscription sur la liste
d'attente pour que les gens puissent ce
réguler ce flux de demande parce qu'on
on sait qu'on est en punierie majeure
euh voilà avec des délis je vous ai dit
de 24 mois et puis sur le ça c'est
l'autoconservation c'est aussi un sujet
qui euh qui a alors là je pense que
c'est une deuxème révolution c'est que
là on est aussi sur une demande qui
explose notamment en Île-de-France euh
avec et qui ne faiblit pas c'est que ça
je pense que maintenant ça va devenir
quelque chose de presque de routine pour
des jeunes femmes d'aller faire
conserver leur 30 ans leur leurs ovocit
voilà qu'elles utiliseront ou qu'elles
utiliseront pas l'expérience qu'on a
dans d'autres pays européens c'est que
ils les utiliseent à peu près pour 40 %
d'entre elles mais ça peut être aussi
moi je me dis une source de don de vos
sites comme je vous ai dit qu'on était
en pénuriie on peut se dire que toutes
les jeunes femmes peuvent proposer à la
une fois qu'elles peuvent plus les
utiliser soit les détruire soit les
donner à des à des couples en attente de
Don donc ça peut aussi être une source
mais en tout cas on est clairement pour
l'instant dans une tension très forte
d'accès au soins parce que c'est réservé
au centre public et il y a une demande
pour que ce soit ouvert au centre privé
parce que sachant que quand vous avez à
l'étranger c'est des centres privés qui
font cette autoconservation et là il y a
un recours très fort voilà et donc c'est
surtout en Île-de-France he qu'on a des
délais alors là vous avez des délais
moyens en Île-de on est à 8 mois à peu
près France entière à 14 mois pour pour
l'île-de-fance mais c'est un des les les
fossé ce que nous disent les
professionnels c'est que la grande
majorité des jeunes femmes vont à
l'étranger pour leur autoconservation
maintenant que c'est remboursé parce
qu'elles ont des délis beaucoup moins
cours en
Espagne voilà et là aussi làâ je c'est
en gros en majorité plutôt des jeunes
femmes vous voyez on a qui qui comm là
c'est autorisé à partir de 29 ans à
l'autoconservation vous voyez que c'est
en grande majorité plutôt à 35 voilà
c'est quand les jeunes femmes se rendent
compte qu'elles ont pas encore eu une
grossesse dans un contexte on va dire
plus classique ell elle préfèrent aller
se dire si je peux Garner quelques mois
de préservation de ma fertilité je je
j'y vais donc à partir de 35
ans euh très rapidement sur les les
chiffres clés sur la génétique médicale
qui est aussi un sujet euh qui est
devant nous euh parce que on on a
euh on a en fait énormément une ce que
les professionnels nous disent un
tsunami de demande parce que vous savez
que maintenant on va y revenir dans les
présentations on on a de plus en plus de
de typages génétiques qui se font dans
de multiples circonstances euh et qui
permettent de savoir de de de savoir si
vous allez être bien répondre à une
pathologie à une thérapeutique si vous
avez une prédisposition à une paologie
ou autre et dès que on commence à faire
ces ces diagnostics parce qu' AC l'exome
maintenant c'est devenu assez accessible
le problème c'est que vous devez vous
découvrir des choses qui du coup avec
concern aussi vos ascendants vos
descendants enfin donc il y a une
demande exponentielle qui est en train
d'arriver et qui devient un peu de
routine enfin qui et qui peut aussi qui
est très intéressante pour limiter les
ranceces diagnostiqu parce qu'on se rend
compte qu'il y a beaucoup de pathologies
chronique quand vous faites des des
exomes où on se rend compte on arrive à
poser des diagnostiques qu'on n'arrivait
pas à poser avant mais avec des derrière
une une offre de soins qui n'est pas
encore prête à à encaisser cette cette
demande parce que c'est voilà ça va être
c'est ça c'est on l'a pas encore
complètement documenté ça va être un de
nos objectifs là dans dans les
prochaines années parce que c'est il y a
pas beaucoup de chiffres encore
là-dessus sur cette comme on a pu le
faire sur la M mais on voit bien que
c'est les sujets de demain voilà donc de
toute façon vous aurez t tout enfin je
vous laisserai ça et on on a toutes les
données aussi dans nos dans nos rapports
d'Activ
donc ça c'est un c'est je pense que
c'était important que vous pour vous
donner un peu le le cadre de de la
demande si si je balayille maintenant
alors je suis accompagné de mon
directeur médical et scientifique qui
est Michel le professeur Michel
simaratos qui on va se faire un peu à de
voix vous vous balayer peut-être vos
votre questionnaire pour et et surtout
n'hésitez pas à nous interrompre parce
que je pense que ça ça permet aussi de
d'avoir un dialogue avec vous par qu'on
sera peut-être pas forcément au clair
sur toutes les les questions alors votre
première question c'est la l'état des
lieux de la loi de bioéthique on vous
donnera tous les éléments en gros tous
les textes sont sortis donc voilà le
dernier est sorti le au j du 31 décembre
2023 donc voilà le sur le la génétique
donc tous les textes sont sortis donc on
a on est maintenant en état de de
fonctionner vous nous aviez demandé
après un un état des lieux des
différents plans d'action donc je pense
que là vous avez je je vous ai répondu
sur les principaux points clés euh on
pourra y revenir s'il y a des questions
spécifiques qui qui vous qui vous
intéressent mais en gros on est sur la
partie juste un petit point sur la
partie AMP justement nos comités de
suivi dont je vous ai parlé qu'on a mis
en place pour les trois plans sont
vraiment intéressants parce que c'est là
où c'est grâce à ce comité de suivi
qu'on a pu suivre en temps réel
l'augmentation de la demande la pression
et adapter les financements et les
moyens disponibles pour les
établissement il y a eu un effort
colossal hein de plus de 16 millions
d'euros en supplémentaire pour
accompagner la montée en puissance des
des centres au voilà depuis en 2 ans
quoi donc c'est c'est pas rien et c'est
justement ce dialogue permanent avec les
associations de patients avec les les
professionnels qui ont permis de de
répondre à ces demandes euh vous nous
avveit posé une question sur notre
rapport notre 5e rapport d'information
au Parlement au gouvernement sur les les
les perspectives un petit peu donc je
vais peut-être passer la parole à Michel
simaratos qui va vous donner les là
aussi on vous a détaillé mais les grands
plans de les grands points ça
merci marine mesdames et messieurs donc
le le le RPG ou le rapport d'information
Parlement et et au
gouvernement vise à assurer une une
information permanente sur ces progrès
et donc on a abordé dans ce document qui
est qui est paru à la fin de l'année
2023 une une analyse des des points les
plus marquants et de leur conséquences
en terme d'organisation des soins en
terme de qualité de prise en charge
en terme d'éthique et plus globalement
en terme de santé publique concernant la
greffe on a abordé dans la greffe le les
les techniques l'analyse des techniques
les plus prometteuses comme la
xénotransplantation on y reviendra
peut-être au cours de la discussion sur
le fait que ça ouvre un certain nombre
de perspectives mais que ça ça oriente
aussi un petit peu le regard sur le fait
que les risques qui sont portés par ces
techniques doivent être pris en compte
notamment sur le risque de transmission
interespèces d'un certain nombre de
maladies et de virus qui peuvent
être génétiquement intégrés au au génome
de l'animal qui a été utilisé pour
fabriquer ces greffons ces ces organes
il y a
aussi l'idée que la
greffe c'est une solution mais c'est pas
une guérison et donc on analyse
l'ensemble de ces techniques à la
lumière d'un d'un parcours de maladie
chronique qui est une alternance entre
de la greffe et la lutte contre le rejet
et le retour à une forme de substitution
de l'organe comme par exemple la dialyse
on peut le faire aussi pour un court
lapse de temps pour le cœur ou le foie
ou le poumon mais évidemment on peut pas
vivre avec un poumon artificiel ou avec
un cœur artificiel très longtemps donc
on essaie de de mettre en perspective
toutes ces possibilités et toutes ces
évolutions techniques pour comprendre
comment la pénurie d'organe peut
bénéficier à un moment donné de
techniques comme l'xénotransplantation
il y a aussi d'autres techniques comme
vous avez peut-être entendu parler de de
crispe qui est qui permet de modifier le
génome ça permet dans certains cas de de
transformer une partie du génome qui
code pour ce qui va générer le rejet et
pour diminuer cette importance du rejet
on a abordé aussi le la façon et comment
la technique peut nous aider à mieux
appar
le donneur et le receveur vous savez
qu'on a tous une carte d'identité
biologique qui s'appelle qu'on appelle
le HLA pour human lococyte antigène et
qu'on et que les HLA sont donnés un allè
vient de notre père et un Allen vient de
notre mère et donc lorsqu'on fait une
greffe c'est l'incompatibilité HLA entre
le donneur et le receveur qui va être un
élément de stimulation du rejet plus le
HLA du donneur et du receveur compatible
moins les phénomènes de rejet vont
s'activer précocément et plus la greffe
va durer longtemps c'est pas le seul
déterminant mais c'est un des
déterminants et donc l'amélioration des
techniques de dosage de de C de CL nous
permett d'avoir aujourd'hui des des de
proposer aux patients des greffes avec
une une très forte
compatibilité c'est une des raisons pour
lesquelles marine vous disait tout à
l'heure que beaucoup des des receveurs
euh de de greffe de moelle reçoivent une
moelle qui vient de l'étranger parce
qu'on recherche l'identité HLA et que
cette identité et bien on va la chercher
dans le monde entier dans les 70
registres qui sont connectés pour
trouver la meilleure identité
à on a aussi euh proposé différentes euh
façons d'optimiser la loocation des
greffants parce que nous sommes en
situation de pénurie marine janté vous a
illustré le fait que chaque jour trois
personnes décède sur la liste d'attente
et donc cette pénurie nous amène à
réfléchir sur la manière dont on on on
va faire la loocation des greffons et
cette manière jusqu'à présent on
utilisait ce qu'on appelle les scores on
en parle aussi dans une autre question
mais on peut déjà illustrer ça le score
c'est une façon de réfléchir à
l'ensemble des déterminants pour
affecter le meilleur greffon à la
meilleure personne au bon moment par
exemple si vous êtes en quelqu'un qui
est en en attente d'un d'une greffe
cardiaque on va être probablement tenté
de faire passer en priorité les gens les
qui sont le plus gravement atteints mais
parfois ceux qui sont le plus gravement
atteints sont atteints en raison d'une
maladie globale qui peut diminuer les
chances de de succès dans le temps de
ces greffes et on avait avant
l'utilisation d'un score pour la greffe
de
cœur l'impression que ceux qui étaient
le moins gravement atteint étai ceux qui
passaient en dernier
et donc cette prime à la gravité ne
teneit pas compte du du pourcentage de
vie que qui pouvait y avoir à la suite
de la greffe le score nous permet
d'intégrer un risque de décès
indépendamment de la gravité de la
maladie et donc ça permet de
rééquilibrer et de et de d'avoir une une
gestion intelligente de la pénurie
toutes les techniques d'IA évidemment
nous aide puisque les scores sont en
fait une préfiguration de ce que nous
permet de faire
lia pour euh euh dans dans le domaine de
l'embryologie et la génétique on en a
déjà un peu parlé euh euh le le
l'assistance médicale à la procréation
bénéficie aussi de tous ces progrès par
exemple les techniques d'IA ou de ou de
ou d'image de très haute définition
permettent permettre à des systèmes
guidés par l'intelligence artificielle
de sélectionner le meilleur embryon à
implanter et donc vous savez qu'en
France aujourd'hui on on implante plus
que un parfois deux embryons euh parce
que euh on on veut éviter les grossesses
multiples qui ont d'autres d'autres
impacts sur la santé des femmes et des
enfants et donc l'intelligence
artificielle nous permet d'avancer
là-dessus on faisait un point assez
précis sur sur ces
aspects on on a aussi abordé les
techniques de conservationvocitaire ou
l'obtention de cellules gamétiques à
partir de cellules Souch ce sont tous
ces ces points de progrès qu'on a essayé
d'illustrer dans dans le rapport de
manière à à permettre une information
la la plus complète possible et et au
goût du jour de des des progrès de la
recherche en je on vous adressera ce
document qui est qui qui présente toutes
ces tous ces points pour la génétique je
reviens une minute sur l'irance
diagnostique vous savez qu'aujourd'hui
la majeure partie de la mobilisation de
notre système de santé est faite pour
les maladies chronique et qui s'exprime
dans la deuxème partie de la vie
beaucoup de ces maladies chroniques
sontc ouverte au stade d'insuffisance
terminale de l'organe parfois un peu
plus tôt dans la vie les ces pathologies
peuvent bénéficier de de techniqu
d'avancer mais par exemple dans le
retard mental on est aujourd'hui en
mesure d'utiliser le les progrès en
génétique pour diminuer les range
diagnostique c'est-à-dire
caractériser la maladie sur le plan
moléculaire quand on caractérise la
maladie sur le plan moléculaire que ça
soit pour du retard mental ou pour une
maladie chronique on est en mesure d'
identifier la cible sur laquelle on peut
faire porter un certain nombre de
progrès thérapeutiques l'enzymothérapie
les carticelles le les le les progrès de
la pharmacopé nous permettent
aujourd'hui avec cette diminution de
l'érance thérapeutique et la définition
des cibles moléculaires de préciser et
de transformer certaines maladies très
handicapantes comme par exemple la
maladie de Fabri ou la maladie de Hunter
qui sont des maladies d'accumulation
d'un produit intermédiaire du
métabolisme en personnes qui àaide d'une
perfusion par exemple d'une enzyme tous
les 15 jours ou tous les mois peuvent
suivre un chemin de vie
normal réduction de l'impact de du
handicap et insertion c'est donc des
techniques qui permettent de transformer
ce qui était jusqu'à présant une charge
pour le système en des personnes actives
qui sont insérées dans la vie courante
et donc ça c'est c'est des points
extrêmement importants qui sur lesquels
on a un peu insisté dans ce rapport je
n'oublie pas les cellules souches et
notamment euh marine janté vous a vous
en a parlé les cellules souches
reprogrammées elle vous a parlé des
carticells les carticelles comme elle
vous l'a dit c'est prendre les cellules
cancéreuses d'une personne qui souffre
d'un cancer identifier euh les les les
épitopes c'est-à-dire les antigènes
spécifiques au cancer et reconditionner
les cellules de la même personne pour
combattre les cellules qui exprime
l'épitope du cancer donc on transforme
des cellules en médicaments alors c'est
extrêmement coûteux nous sommes très
attachés à ce qu'on puisse se souvenir
que la matière première est une
matière vivante qui provient d'un don
anonyme et gratuit parce que lorsque ces
médicaments sont sont réinjectés au
patient ils attaquent la tumeur et ils
transformment ils font en sorte que
aujourd'hui 80 % des des cancers qui
sont traités sont guéris alors ça ça ne
se fait pas sans mal parce que ça crée
une réaction inflammatoire extrêmement
importante dans l'organisme qui mobilise
les lit de de des services de d'Onco et
qui explique en partie la difficulté au
d'accès au au au service de soins quand
quand il y a des difficultés voilà voilà
pour le le
rapport au gouvernement juste pour être
tout à fait complet sur ces sur ces
aspects
cellules marine janté vous a parlé de de
de la banque d'unités de sang
plasmatique on recueille le sang du
cordon et on le stocke parce que il y a
dans ce sens du cordon des cellules
souches et bien nous avons dans dans
notre banque globale de cellules souche
en France identifier un certain nombre
d'individus qui ont une ce qu'on appelle
une triple homozygosie c'est-à-dire que
beaucoup du HLA qui compose ces cellules
ont ont la même identité provenant du du
père et de la mère or ces cellules
deviennent
un des cellules souches que l'on
pourrait transformer en n'importe quel
effecteur et donc on a là de quoi
imaginer ça viendra peut-être puisqu'on
porte un projet dans ce sens que on
aurait un potentiel de traitement de
type carticell mais
halogénique c'est-à-dire si on peut pas
chez un patient donné récupérer ses
cellules pour les transformer en
cellules effectrices de de tueuse de
cancer on pourrait prendre dans une
banque des cellules souches
pluripotentes et les transformer en en
cellul tueuse de cancer pour ce patient
qui n'est pas le même chez qui on les a
présenté ça n'existe pas pour l'instant
ce n'est que de la recherche mais c'est
donc ça apparaît dans notre rapport au
Parlement et au gouvernement
et projet de de construire une banque
publique de de qu'on appelle d'ips qui
qui y a aucune banque publique
actuellement au monde ell sont toutes
privées et donc on c'est un des projets
qu'on voudrait proposer à notre nouveau
ministre pour en lien avec le FS parce
que c'est eux qui sont dépositeurs de
nos des unités mais je pense que ça
c'est en terme de recherche et de
potentiel c'est assez intéressant parce
qu'on on a une matière première et on
est voilà c'est c'est aussi ce serait
aussi une manière de valoriser
l'excellence de la de la recherche
française euh ensuite vous aviez donc
une question sur les activités de
prélèvement et de greffe d'organes je
pense que je vous ai un peu déjà répondu
sur le sur le sujet de toute façon vous
aurez le le le détail il y avait une
question sur les les scores je pense que
Michel cimaratos vient de vous en de
vous l'exposer donc on avait après une
question sur les les dons croisés là
aussi je vous ai dit pour l'instant on
est encore un peu au milieu du gay parce
que on n pas assez de proposition mais
on y travaille et puis je vous cache pas
que les dons croisé enfin vu
qu'actuellement c'est un peu la même
sujet qu'on a avec le don du vivant
c'est que ça nécessite de blocs en même
temps et donc le don croisé c'est encore
pire donc là il y a un sujet logistique
en plus qui est aggravé par le par les
tensions actuelles dans les les unités
de soins dans les unités de des hôpitaux
pour qui ne nous facilite pas mais ça
n'empêche pas de c'est c'est pas ça pour
l'instant le premier problème c'est
qu'on a on n pas assez de proposition
pour faire des apparillements on a un
âge après vous aviez la question 8 qui
nous proposer des questions sur le sur
l'âge de des donneurs on a c'est un âge
qui augmente faut que vous sachiez que
on prélève de plus en plus tard ce qui
est voilà donc on on prélève même
jusqu'à plus de 80 ans he c'est ce qu'on
on a Paris comme vous avez vu les
besoins nous quand les parce que vous
pouvez mourir à 96 ans avoir des reins
en parfait état et et sil y a des gens
de 70 ans ou 75 ans qui ont besoin
d'être greffés ben voilà il vaut mieux
évidemment on va le ils sont prversac
rester en dialyse c'est c'est pas rien
ceci dit nous en terme de gestion parce
que quand vous êtes plus âgé vous avez
plus de pathologie chronique aussi
associé de comorbidité donc on a aussi
adapté toutes les
recommandation pour les les les
préleveurs pour qu'il puissent qualifier
les dons parce que effectivement c'est
pas parce que vous avez un cancer que
vous êtes pas prélevable tout dépend
deelel type de cancer voilà il y a des
des organes qui sont pas touchés du tout
par le cancer et il y a pas de risque de
transmission donc il y a on a aussi
clarifié ces ces ces
recommandations on vous y avez la
question neu portée sur le le la baisse
des des des personnes qui sont mort
encéphaliie qui sont qui étent la
principale source de donneur on a
effectivement déployer le protocole
masrich 3 dont je vous ai parlé qui est
en train de vraiment de bien progresser
donc ça c'est c'est une bonne nouvelle
mais là aussi ça c'est très mobilisateur
de ressources mais ça ça ça se développe
plutôt bien donc on est on est assez
content sur ce sujet on avait après la
question 10 sur les
greffes
composites et donc je peux sur les
toutes les les nouvel types de grves
donc Michel tu veux peut-être en dire un
mot rapidement et sur lesexè grve même
si tu en as déjà un petit peu parlé ouis
je reviens pas sur l'excénogreff sauf si
vous voulez avoir des précisions
peut-être pour vous dire que aujourd'hui
l'ex Greff ne peuvent pas être considéré
comme la réponse à la pénurie d'organe
pour des raisons extrêmement simples
c'est-à-dire c'est que c'est pas
suffisamment fiable pour remplacer le
nombre d'organes qui manque voyez il
manque presque trois ou quatre organes
par jour et c'est très cher c'est très
cher et puis c'est c'est une technologie
qui est captive aujourd'hui des
États-Unis d'une entreprise qui est qui
a qui a développé ce modèle là il y a 20
ans donc bon on on c'est vrai que nous
étions dans la course mais on n pas
embrayé et donc là ça voudrait dire
qu'on est qu' qu'on repose il faut faire
toute la recherche clinique qu'elle
aboutisse en se basant sur le business
model d'une entreprise qui est une
entreprise
commerciale mais je pense qu'on a aussi
d'autres éléments pour pour aller
chercher ce manque de greffon marine
vous l'a dit d'abord la diminution du
besoin en agissant sur la prévention et
sur la partie en amont de la partie
terminale de la maladie chronique on on
a de plusieurs projets dans dans ce
sens-là et puis ensuite en en améliorant
un petit peu les choses on parle là des
alogreff composite c'est ce qu'on
appelle les greffes de visage quand on
greffe un organe euh je si vous êtes
familier avec la différence entre greffe
et transplantation la greffe c'est en
général du tissu c'est-à-dire qu'il y a
pas de suture de vaisseau et la
transplantation c'est la la greffe d'un
organe dont on doit suturer les
vaisseaux pour pour alimenter en
l'organe et le la partie spécifique de
l'organe pour le foie c'est les canaux
biliaires pour les reins c'est l'urterre
pour le cœur c'est
l'aorte les vaisseaux qui nourrissent le
cœur étant les coronnaires ils sont
transplantés avec l'organe et pour les
poumons c'est la traché et bien dans les
greffes composites on greffe plusieurs
organes et on doit organiser la greffe
pour que l'ensemble de cette chirurgie
puisse permettre à cette composition
d'organe de fonctionner les la la greffe
de la face hein il y en a eu
quelquesunes qui ont été faites en
greffe des muscles greffe des nerfs on
greffe des vaisseaux on greffe des
canaux des des épithéliumes donc ces
greffes composites elles dépendent
beaucoup de la qualification du receveur
comment va-t-on être certain que le
receveur est en mesure de recevoir la
greffe et de la qualification du donneur
c'est un travail considérable que font
les coordinations en lien avec les
professionnels
si on voit d'autres dans d'autres
domaines on a des greffes de de tissu
qu'on avait du mal à greffer jusqu'à
présent pour des questions par exemple
de conservation la trachée ou les
branches aujourd'hui on est en mesure de
de greffer lorsqu'on a des sténoses ou
des nécroses d'un bout de traché donc
qui relie les voies aériennes
supérieures au au poumon et bien on est
en mesure aujourd'hui non plus de mettre
une prothèse mais de mettre du matériel
humain qui a été prélevé chez une
personne
décédée on a aussi les les greffes
d'utérus alors vous savez que l'absence
congénital d'utérus évidemment
compromet la la la réalisation d'une
d'une grossesse et mais qu'on sait que
lorsqu'on prélève l'utérus chez une
personne qui n'a qui a terminé son cycle
de fertilité c'est-à-dire après la
ménopause et bien si on l'expose de
nouveau à un environnement hormonal
compatible l'utérus va être en mesure
d'accueillir un enfant ça a été fait à
plusieurs reprises c'est dans les pays
nordiques que les gens sont le plus
avancés mais nous avons en France un
programme de recherche qui permet de
mener à bien des grossesses ça c'est des
naissan naiss qui est à la deè
naissance exactement c'est la greffe du
terus de sa maman évidemment il s'agit
de de prendre l'utérus d'une personne de
le transplanter à une personne qui est
encore en mesure mesure d'avoir un
enfant et puis de l'explanter à la fin
du projet de grossesse donc c'est
aujourd'hui encore de la recherche
comment sinon vousez vous devez
conserver un traitement
immunosuppresseur donc c'est voilà c'est
pas il y a une balance bénéfice risque
une fois que vous avez eu des grossesses
normalement vous avez pas besoin
deutérus pour vivre donc donc ça génère
aussi un certain nombre de tension
éthique et en terme de politique de
santé quand on quand on met en place des
pr comme cela c'est pour ça que c'est
pas encore des ce des soins courants
hein c'est encore du du programme de
recherche mais en tout cas ça permet
d'avancer là-dessus et
puis le cur artificiel juste un mot pour
vous dire que le cœur artificiel
aujourd'hui il y a des entreprises
françaises he qui proposent des
prothèses de cur artificiel que qui
peuvent permettre de vivre plusieurs
jours avec le avec un cur artificiel et
permettre d'attendre une greffe
cardiaque voilà ensuite vous aviez une
question sur la la 11 sur lia alors on y
a déjà un petit peu parlé donc en gros
l'a nous aide pour les répartitions de
de d'organ Michel parlait aussi de de la
sélection du meilleur embryon ça joue
aussi sur les les diagnosticqus anatal
quand on fait des l'analyse des
séquenages c'est aussi les analyses sont
fait grâce à lia donc on est sur la
partie compatibilité Hel pour les greves
de cellules souche donc voilà c'est déjà
un peu en routine enfin on utilise déjà
lia en routine pour quand il pour dirit
pour oui structurer des données très
complexes qu'il faut analyser très vite
pour faire le meilleur choix pour le
pour le patient on pourra y revenir si
vous le souhaitez vous avvez appris une
question 12 sur les tout ce qui était
AMP les délais d'attente je pense que là
aussi je vous avvez présenté au départ
donc je je ne m'apesantis pas là-dessus
pour pour pour laisser un peu de temps
aux questions une question aussi sur le
fait qu'il y avait une baisse de qualité
la question 1 sur la baisse de qualité
du sperme et l'augmentation de lagfam
est-ce que ça va mettre en tension
bon je pense que c'est un sujet mais
c'est pas le le vrai sujet je pense
qu'il est sociétal entre nous hein c'est
on voit qu'il y a une évolution les
déterminant de là on voit bien qu'il y a
vous l'avez vu la baisse de la natalité
c'est pas que lié au fait que de
l'infertilité hein c'est que il y a
aussi les jeunes femmes maintenant on
une manière de de de de se développp
enfin on nont pas forcément des projets
de grossesse à tout prix dans leur
parcours de vie elles le font de plus en
plus tard pour parce qu'elles ont aussi
veulent avoir une vie prof n donc c'est
et voir même certains ne veulent pas
d'enfants enfin vous avez entendu les
nouvelles voilà il y a un tournant aussi
dans les jeunes générations donc je je
pense que le système de soin est capable
de de gérer on le voit parce que c'est
le sujet
mais la réponse à à la baisse de la
natalité je pense pas que c'est qu'un
sujet d'infertilité c'est plutôt un
sujet voilà il me semble c'est
les la question 14 sur la partie
développement des neurosciences donc
effectivement on a une nouvelle mission
que nous a confié le parle ement on a
donc mis en place des
lettres on a publié deux lettres sur les
neurosciences donc une justement sur
l'IA et une sur le développement des
neurosciences qui sont à votre
disposition et effectivement qui
donneent là c'est vraiment très
prospectif et on va en faire la
prochaine c'est sur tu sur la les
organoïdes voilà donc du cerveau sur les
interfaces homme machine là qui sont
très intéressant aussi on pourra y
revenir mais c'est que là il y a tout un
enjeu aussi de où on va dans la dans
l'interface et dans l'ingérence dans la
dans le cerveau humain parce que c'est
c'est ça aussi avec la prise de pouvoir
est-ce qui nous à chaque fois on dit il
faut toujours que l'homme garde le
contrôle de ce qui se passe et non pas
la machine ne devienne pas bah oui non
mais c'est la science-fiction devient
réalité là quand même sur un N de de
sujetse sur ce oui vas-y ouais
vas-y euh de de de l'information dans
les neurosciences notre démarche a été
vraiment de de de de s'installer dans
une dimension de production de
connaissan stratégique c'est-à-dire que
on a intitulé notre lettre de de
l'Agence de la biomédecine lettre de
veille stratégique en santé parce que on
est au moment où il faut prendre des
décisions hein il y a un seul un seul
État au monde qui a mis dans ces textes
réglementaires et législatifs le
neurodroit
c'est-à-dire si demain on on vous
injecte quelque chose dans le cerveau
pour guérir une maladie et que ce
quelque chose est connecté à qui
appartiennent les données si demain on
vous aide à vous endormir par des
mécanismes qui recueille de l'activité
cérébrale à qui appartiennent ces
données est-ce qu'elles appartiennent à
l'entreprise qui a fabriqué la puce ou à
vous ou au système et donc ça a des
impacts qui sont considérables parce que
on si vous lisez les deux l de veille il
y en a une qui est sur les
neurotechnologies c'est-à-dire la façon
dont on peut envisager l'homme augmenté
bon aujourd'hui il y a des guerres
partout toutes les armées ont sont à la
pointe de la recherche
pour le le le soldat augmenté mieux visé
mieux arrivé mieux et c'est l'armée qui
est le principal fournisseur de
recherche dans ce domaine là donc nous
notre but c'est d'informer que ben il
faut pas prendre de retard là-dedans la
deuxième lettre étant sur l'intelligence
artificielle c'est-à-dire comment cette
façon d'optimiser un processus récurrent
peut agir sur l'impact que ça peut avoir
on parlait tout à l'heure de des données
et du neurodroit mais on peut aussi
peut-être aller un petit peu plus loin
sur la façon dont on on pourrait
automatiser certaines prises de
décisions on revient dans le secteur de
l'armée mais ça peut aussi exister dans
dans la la le côté
civil on n'est pas si loin des premiers
logiciels qui vont optimiser l'accès au
bloc en fonction de paramètres basés sur
un un un algorithme d' intelligence
artificielle donc c'est c'est cette
démarche d'information du Parlement et
du gouvernement dans dans ces domaineslà
s'inscrit dans une réflexion stratégique
pour permettre pour éclairer la décision
et pour vous permettre de de d'anticiper
ce qui va se passer dans 5 ans dans 10
ans donc après il y a deux dernières
questions que une question sur le La
recherche sur les les les les embryons
donc effectivement le le nous considère
que les ajustements de la dernière loi
sont plutôt euh intéressants euh donc
depuis que la loi a été promulguée on a
instruit 13 déclaration de de recherche
sur les cellules souches embryonnaires
et euh cette déclaration de conservation
euh en fait ça ça fonctionne plutôt bien
clairement les délais d'instruction ont
été extrêmement réduits par ces
nouvelles procédures parce que on a
toujours pu les les analyser en avec
l'expertise interne de l'agence sans
avoir recours à des experts extérieurs
et du coup ça je pense pens que c'est un
bon équilibre nous on trouve he que ça
ça a permis de donner un peu de
plusidité sur certaines demandes qui
sont qui sont bien qui sont plus qui
tout en respectant l'encadrement
évidemment qui sont plus rapidement
regardés donc pour permettre des
recherche plus rapide quoi le délai de
conservation qui est inscrit dans la loi
vous nous convient pour l'instant par
contre on voudrait attirer votre
attention on a le conseil d'orientation
de l'agence a rendu un avis en octobre
dernier c'est une première mondiale sur
les les modèles embryonnaires
euh on on attire votre attention sur cet
avis parce qu'en fait justement on dit
que ce n'est pas un embryon mais que ce
n'est pas non plus des cellules
pluripotantes donc il y a il y a il y a
en fait la réglementation sur les
cellules les IPs serait un petit peu
trop souple pour ces modèles et la
recherche sur l'embryon serait un peu
trop dure et donc il faut peut-être
qu'on trouve en terme de révision de de
de permettre un un encadrement
spécifique pour ces types de modèles euh
qui qui sont en train de se développer
vitesse grand V hein à chaque fois c'est
c'est voilà nos délais de de législatif
de 5 à séances parfois ne sont pas comm
forcément compatible donc nous on
trouverait ça intéressant qu'au moins
sur ce volet là sans faire forcément une
révision de toute la loi peut-être aussi
qu'on soit peut-être plus souple sur nos
nos Modalités de d'ajustement du cadre
législatif sur un un un aspect en
particulier pour pour s'adapter à
l'évolution de la science à un moment
donné qui va parfois plus vite sans
avoir la toute la lourdeur d'une
révision complète du cadre
euh voilà donc ça c'est un des un des
points et puis dernière question et non
la moindre sur les tests génétiques euh
alors là c'est aussi une explosion hein
enfin de de de demande avec les tests
sur génétiques sur Internet vous savez
qu'il sont interdits en France on on est
vraiment nous très très rétissant à
enfin très méfiant sur ces tests parce
qu'on voit qu'il y a beaucoup d'effets
pervers à la fois de non encadrement de
l'annonce parce qu'en fait comme je vous
le disais maintenant on trouve
énormément de choses hein sur l'exo et
donc vous allez euh on va découvrir soit
des prédispositions à des cancers soit
des tout tout ça vous AZ envoyé par la
poste c'est pas encadré euh c'est pas
donc c'est quand même avec des des
impacts sur le reste de la famille qui
sont pas du tout du coup organisés euh
avec parfois des analyse de qualité non
vérifié en plus on est même pas sûr de
la qualité de certaines présentations
euh et puis donc je je pense qu'il faut
faire il y a d'ailleurs un film on vous
a mis qui va sortir un film grand public
qui va sortir sur ce sujet-là avec
l'Impact ça et la méconnaissance donc je
pense qu'il y a vraiment un enjeu
beaucoup plus fort que ce qu'on fait
actuellement d'information du public sur
les risques de ces tests surtout
qu'après il y a un sujet de conservation
de vos
données des adenes parce qu'une fois que
vous avez envoyé votre échantillon
biologique il est dans des banques de
données et ce qui fait que par exemple
même si ça part aux États-Unis la FD
après peut être capable de vous
reconnaître vous et vos proches sur le
plan génétique sans vous ayez donné
votre accord sur quoi que ce soit
là-dessus donc il y a je pense qu'il y a
un risque non enfin à la fois médicale
éthique de protection des libertés qu'il
faut vraiment euh à mon avis enfin un
peu plus insister que c'est pas un sujet
qui pour l'instant tout le monde voit le
côté ah bah c'est marrant je vais savoir
de de quelle origine je suis de mais en
fait derrière les gens ne se rendent pas
compte que ces données peuvent générer
des choses terribles contre eux à la
fois sur le plan individuel si jamais on
découvre une pathologie et sans que ce
soit organisé et du coup pas de parcours
de soin prévu et cetera
et et après l'utilisation à des fins bah
d'identification qui peu enfin voilà qui
peuvent leur poser problèmes dans
d'autres contextes et géopolitique hein
c'est-à-dire que c'est quand quand vous
envoyez par la poste et qu'on vous
envoie une réponse génétique on vous
renvoie une carte en disant vous êtes 10
% de du bassin méditerranéen 5 % de là 5
% de là en fait si vous si on imagine la
la la collection l'entreprise qui arrive
à collecter le Big Data c'est-à-dire
l'ensemble de ces données elle crée une
carte avec ça et ça ça a des impacts
considérables par exemple industriel
c'est-à-dire bah le le le on sait déjà
que il y a 50 % de consanguinité dans le
la péninsule arabique on peut déjà dire
quelles sont les maladies qui vont
s'exprimer dans les 30 prochaines
années donc ça veut dire qu'on peut
aussi dimensionner notre réponse
industrielle médicament service de soins
et cetera à ce qui va se passer on sait
qu'au États-Unis il y a 38 % de de
préobèse à l'âge de 20 ans c'est-à-dire
que on on aujourd'hui Sanofi par exemple
est capable de dimensionner sa réponse
industrielle à la production
d'antidiabéti et de de de médicaments
contre l'obésité dans le marché de de
l'obésité si à ça on rajoute les gènes
de susceptibilité de développer une
insuffisance rénale chronique qui va
être accélérée par par le diabète mais
on a euh une transformation euh de de de
de de la base de connaissance qui va
permettre à certaines entreprise ou
parfois à certaines visées politiques
peut-être un peu plus globales de
s'appuyer sur quelque chose qui a été
généré par notre envie de faire euh un
cadeau sympa en disant bah tiens on va
voir si on est on a effectivement euh
des ascendances grec ou euh ou
arménienne ou je sais pas quoi euh dans
dans notre dans dans notre euh
ascendance or en réalité c'est pas si
simple que ça et ça porte un risque qui
est un risque global pour la société et
c'est ça qu'on essaie de mettre en avant
dans notre
communication sans jeter un vent de
panique hein puisque vous verrez la
bandeannonce et le film si vous allez le
voir que tout ça est abordé par le
billet sociétal de est-ce que je viens
vraiment de là où je pense
venir donc nous notre
notre notre idée depuis en tout cas
qu'on s'occupe de ça c'est de de générer
de la connaissance à haute valeur
ajoutée c'est-à-dire de de privilégier
la connaissance à la notoriété il s'agit
pas de faire beaucoup de vues sur les
réseaux avec des des petites phrases
parce que ça ça donne beaucoup de
beaucoup de visibilité mais après
produire du du contenu de haute valeur
ajoutée sur lequel on peut appuyer une
réflexion pour aboutir à une stratégie
bah c'est un peu plus difficile et quand
ça ne s'appuie que sur de la notoriété
on on sait bien maintenant les diff ulté
qu'on peut y avoir donc nous avons
organisé toute notre communication
scientifique et institutionnelle autour
de ça une information complète du grand
public par le biais des réseaux et une
information orientée du Parlement et du
gouvernement des professionnels et des
association à travers une un un spectre
de publication qui touche tout le monde
les parlementaires le gouvernement les
professionnels à travers les journaux
professionnels et à travers la
participation à des congrès les
associations en répondant et en et en
mettant en place une politique de
démocratie sanitaire qui implique les
patients à chaque niveau de de
l'activité de l'agence et le grand
public en s'appuyant sur les réseaux on
a une on a aujourd'hui une une
visibilité totalement incroyable et
inimaginable sur les réseaux quand on
compare à ce qui se faisait juste avant
voilà on est à votre disposition c'est
on était un peu long mais je pense qu'il
y av eu beaucoup de choses à à vous
présenter et à votre disposition pour
répondre à toutes vos questions
merci à vous deux c'était effectivement
très complet on avait envoyé un
questionnaire assez assez
long pour justement auss de balayer
l'ensemble des questions je rappelle à
mes collègues que cette loi de
bioéthique de 2021 doit faire l'objet de
manière obligatoire d'une révision dans
un délai de 7 ans mais doit aussi faire
l'objet d'une évaluation par l'OPEX dans
un dél de 4 ans donc ça veut dire que
Fall c'était c'était août 2021 on a
encore un peu de temps mais on n'est pas
obligé on n'est pas obligé de copier
l'administration et d'attendre le
dernier moment pour se saisir des des
opportunités qui sont devant nous donc
avis aux amateurs pour se se projeter
sur une future évaluation de cette loi
de biéthique de 2021 en en attendant une
éventuelle nouvelle loi à
venir chers collègues est-ce que vous
avez des questions complémentaires à
poser nos deux
intervenants
Corine merci
beaucoup
juste deux deux sujets très différents
parce que je je
m'occupe je m'occupe avec d'autres
actuellement d'un d'un rapport sur les
enjeux les nouveaux enjeux de
l'intelligence artificielle et donc
avoir peut-être un petit peu plus de de
détails sur vous avez déjà beaucoup
parlé de des nouvelles perspectives mais
on a comment est-ce que vous appréhendez
justement la l'utilisation euh la plus
utile euh de de l'intelligence
artificielle parce que on sait qu'il y a
des domaines dans lesquels c'est
extrêmement efficace aujourd'hui puis il
y en a d'autres où euh euh souvent parce
que la masse de
données qui permet à l'intelligence
artificielle de développer n'est pas
suffisante les diagnostics notamment ne
sont pas encore
suffisamment précis pour pour qu'on
puisse s'en servir de manière fiable et
donc cette question de comment est-ce
que on amasse les données suffisantes
mais dans un cadre éthique euh puis
qu'il y a les questions de la
confidentialité des données je sais que
l'acnil aussi travaille là-dessus donc
je sais pas si vous travaillez avec
l'acnil sur ces questions là et donc
comment est-ce que vous vous appréhendez
ce ce dilemme qui est que on a on a
absolument besoin d'avoir une grosse
masse de données pour avoir des IA les
plus efficaces possibles mais que ça
peut poser d'autres problèmes en terme
bah ce que vous venez de dire he de
confidentialité des données
d'utilisation malveillante euh d'une
masse d'une masse de données euh et puis
sur un tout autre sujet euh sur qui n'a
plus rien à voir avec lia sur la
les on a beaucoup parlé de vous avez
beaucoup parlé de de l' m euh j'avais
une question est-ce que il y a des euh
il y a des demandes qui existent par
rapport à ce qui est fait à l'étranger
et notamment euh les techniques qui sont
approuvées en Grande-Bretagne depuis
2016 sur euh les les Fives à trois à
trois gamettes avec avec le l'ovocy
mitochondrial qui est remplacé pour pour
faire pour répondre a des problèmes de
diagnostic génétique problématique
euh et je sais pas du tout si c'est un
sujet bioéthique qui qui est mis sur la
table en France puisque c'est quelque
chose qui existe de manière légale à
l'étranger j'imagine qu'à un moment
donné ça va venir dans le le paysage
voilà euh alors pour pour lia bon ben
vous pointez les aspects les plus les
plus préignants hein donc nous ne sommes
pas les seuls le seul opérateur sur ces
aspects et là il y a un plan qui est le
plan France génomique qui qui vise à
organiser en fait l'ensemble de de des
des données qui vont être produites ce
ce qu'on ce sur quoi nous on alerte
c'est
que il ne s'agit plus simplement des
données pour faire un diagnostic
d'accord il s'agit de données qui vont
avoir un impact exponentiel je je prends
un exemple simple l'exome aujourd'hui
c'est-à-dire l'analyse des parties
codantes de l'ADN euh ben peut être fait
pour trouver une mutation on suspecte
une mutation voilà de la mucovudose et
on veut faire la recherche de cette
mutation chez le le chez le donneur de
spermatozoïdes et chez la donneuse de
vos sititees que ça soit les parents ou
pas pour être sûr que il y a pas un
risque de développement de la
mucovicidose et bien on va si on le fait
par l'exome on va avoir tout le
patrimoine génétique du donneur et tout
le patrimoine génétique de la la
donneuse et donc on va peut-être
découvrir d'autres euh d'autres éléments
par exemple aujourd'hui on les connaît
pas mais demain on va pouvoir découvrir
le gène de susceptibilité à l'Alzheimer
bah dans ce cas-là vous voyez bien que
si on détecte le gène de susceptibilité
à l'Alzheimer chez une personne de 30
ans euh plusieurs questions et plusieurs
tensions éthiques vont se manifester
doit-on lui en parler alors que
aujourd'hui on a que peu d'action
doit-on mettre en place une politique de
prévention doit-on stimuler la recherche
pour aboutir à une politique de
prévention donc tout ça ça fait que
l'ensemble de ces données vont générer
des problèmes auxquels on n' pas encore
pensé et notre travail à nous c'est
d'alerter et d'être en mesure
d'identifier ces problèmes là non pas
pour y apporter une réflexion une
réponse mais pour stimuler la réflexion
en vue d'apporter une réponse donc ça
c'est pour le l'aspect intelligence
artificielle l'intelligence artificielle
va nous aider dans le sens où elle est
capable d'automatiser un certain nombre
de de process notamment d'analyse
euh pour dire bah oui on on il n'y a pas
de gène de je reprends l'Alzheimer
puisquon est dans la fiction n'est-ce
pas il n'y a pas de gène de pour
l'Alzheimer mais ceux qui ont le gène de
l'hypertension artérielle du diabète de
laamylose et de je sais pas quoi
euh ont une probabilité plus forte
d'exprimer et donc on on peut utiliser
des méthodes de calcul d' intelligence
artificielle pour accélérer ce que la
réflexion humaine des scientifiques
faisait en un temps court ça c'est pour
les aspects vertueux de l'intelligence
artificielle l'aspect peut-être un peu
moins vertueux c'est de faire du calcul
de risque et de dire que ben moi je suis
assureur et ceux qui cumulent l'ensemble
de ces de ces allèles et bien soit je ne
les assure pas soit je leur propose une
prime d'assurance qui on va dire les
décourage
d'accéder à quelque chose donc pour
l'intelligence artificielle et pour
essayer d'être synthétique et court pour
la PMA bon on est bien au courant de
toutes ces données et ça existe sur le
plan de la
recherche il y a pas de difficulté à
imaginer le fait que ça passe un jour
dans la pratique courante en France
aujourd'hui c'est réservé à certains à
certaines pathologie très particulière
c'està-dire où l'on sait qu'on a besoin
d'un ADN mitocondrial un petit peu
différent de la même façon aujourd'hui
on sait en recherche
différencier une cellule
ovocitaire en cellulle en gamè
mal donc bon on n'est pas très loin
d'imaginer que le l'amélioration de ces
technique permettra un jour de proposer
la création d'un embryon à partir de
deux ovocytes mais ce n'est pas
aujourd'hui une pratique courante qui
est dans dans nos dans notre domaine
parce que ça ça fait appel à à à à
d'autres à d'autres enjeux que
simplement l'enjeu scientifique et donc
aujourd'hui on est en mesure de répondre
point par point à par exemple ces ces C
ces Fives avec trois personnes mais ce
sont des réponses absolument spécifiques
et lorsqu'elles ne peuvent pas être fait
sur le territoire et bien on peut on
peut s'expatrier pour faire ça
aujourd'hui la principale raison de
l'expatriation pour des questions de
fertilité c'est pas ces questionsl hein
c'est le délai d'attente hein c'est le
délai d'attente d'une d'une femme de 39
ans qui si elle affronte 2 ans d'attente
pour voir son projet se mener à bien
elle aura vu son taux de d'efficacité
des techniques de d'assistance
s'effondré de de de 15 % à moins de 5 %.
et donc ça va plus vite d'aller en
Belgique ou en Espagne puisqueen plus
c'est prise en
charge bonjour à tous et merci pour vos
propos au combien passionnant je
voudrais rebondir sur ces sujets rester
sur la fertilité le président de la
République d'ailleurs a dit qu'il allait
justement il consacrit du budget même si
je partage toalement votre analyse la
baisse de la natalité n n'a pas
évidemment n'est pas expliqué évidemment
par ce problème de de fertilité mais
bien entendu
sociétal je voudrais vous poser une
question à vous deux presque personnelle
mais en tant que représentant évidemment
de l'agence
de la
biomédecine ce modèle justement espagnol
parce que c'est celui qui est le plus
cité dans les problèmes de de ferilité
selon vous est-ce que c'est un
modèle auquel la France
devrait ressembler c'est-à-dire est-ce
que vous vous pensez que c'est un modèle
qui fonctionne puisque quand on voit le
nombre de françaises qui ont recours
alors bien sûr il y a la simplification
administrative et les délais qui sont
plus courts mais il y a aussi beaucoup
de techniques qui sont encore interdites
en France est-ce que c'est un modèle
finalement qu'on devrait essayer de de
euh voilà de de d'y ressembler ou d'y
parvenir ou ils vont beaucoup trop loin
dans cette dans ces dans ces procédés
permissifs et euh bon finalement c'est
un partenaire l'Espagne l'assurance
maladie prend en charge en certaines
conditions euh une PMA faite en Espagne
et finalement ça restera des partenaires
et puis nous on reste comme on est en
France sans trop évoluer donc j'aurais
voulu savoir quelle est votre position
bon dans au Parlement ou celle de
l'exécutif euh quand les les lois sur la
bioéthique sont sont étudiées on on on
peut percevoir bien sûr le les points de
vue chacun mais est-ce que vous en tant
qu'expert voilà c'est un modèle à suivre
l'Espagne ou ils vont trop loin alors
bon la grosse différence entre le modèle
français et le modèle espagnol c'est que
en Espagne c'est surtout des centres
privés qui sont extrêmement voilà qui
sont organisés de manière très efficace
avec mais avec du coup un cout non
négligeable pour les patientes he enfin
c'est voilà c'est donc le avant même de
parler des techniques et des aspects
plus médicaux le gros la grosse
différence elle est là donc il y a
plusieurs sujets il y a d'abord le sujet
de l'autoconservation euh des des
gamettes non médical hein pour des des
ovocytes pour les jeunes femmes que
c'est surtout les jeunes femmes qui ont
recours à cette automédication cette
autoconservation c'est sûr que il y a
une question le Parlement a choisi de
réserver en France ce sujet au au
établissements publics cette question
elle peut être débattue parce que on est
dans un parcours il y a pas un aspect de
Don enfin on n'a pas recours à il y a
pas un besoin d'avoir recours à quelque
chose à un produit du corps humain issu
de d'un don et donc à ce titre là on
peut questionner le cette réserve faite
sur les seuls services publics sachant
que en Espagne ce sont donc on rembourse
sur des dans les centres privés euh et
c'est vrai comme c'est à des fins
personnelles vous savez qu'à peu près 50
% de l'offre de soin d'AMP en France
c'est dans le privé hein donc on peut se
dire bah là de toute façon c'est pour
des fins personnelles c'est des jeunes
femmes qui après peuvent avoir recours à
une classique avec un compagnon elles
iront du coup avec leurs propres ocit
finalement ell le feraiit dans le privé
pourquoi on leur empêche de les
autoconserver dans le privé bon ça c'est
c'est un sujet je pense qui après ça ça
dépendra des des décisions personn des
des de nos tutelles et de et du
Parlement parce qu'il faut passer par la
loi si on doit le changer mais je pense
que c'est quand même un peu dans le sens
de l'histoire enfin de de d'ouvrir cette
possibilité là en France euh après pour
tout ce qui a a recours à un don je
pense qu'il faut rester quand même très
prudent parce que c'est euh voilà on
voit que les dérives sont sont peuvent
arriver quand même assez facilement je
pense qu'on a un cadre en France qui est
assez sécurisant aussi pour pour
organiser les choses euh ce qu'il faut
c'est plutôt susciter plus de dons euh
c'est ce à qualant l'agenceemploi parce
qu'on va arriver bientôt en pénurie de
de de gamettein sur la partart on est
déjà en attention sur les ovocyes donc
je vous dis qu'il y a une possibilité si
justement c'est des jeunes femmes
autoconservent leurs ovocyes mais
finalement n'y ont pas recours parce
qu'elles ont une grossesse par ailleurs
autrement bah se dire voilà il y a je
pense que là il y a peut-être une
sensibilisation de dire est-ce que vous
accepteriez de faire don de vos de ces
ovocyes pour des personnes qui sont en
attente ce qui pourrait réduire de
manière assez drastique bon c'est dans
quelques années hein parce qu'il faut
attendre que là les jeunes femmes qui
viennent de le faire elles ont encore le
temps d'utiliser donc il faut attendre
un petit peu mais donc je pense que ça
c'est une source et pour lesp zoï vous
savez là on n' pas eu de baisse de de
donneur malgré l'ouverture de l'accès
aux origines qui aurait pu être un frein
ce n'est pas un frein en tout cas on le
constate pas actuellement mais pour
autant le nombre de donneurs ne suffit
pas face à la demande c'est dire que là
on a on est en train de reconstituer on
a déjà mutualisé l'ancien stock vous
savez qu'on est jusque jusqu'à mars 2025
pour utiliser le stock anonyme qui
existait parce que il y avait une telle
tension que empêcher l'utilisation de ce
stock ben ça d'abord c'était quand même
des dons hein donc c'est aussi respect
des donneurs et puis derrière ça voulait
dire qu'on avait pas eu le temps de
reconstituer un nouveau stock suffisant
pour faire face à toutes les demandes
mais même avec ça euh avec cette
mutualisation qu'on est en train
d'organiser entre les centres pour
optimiser le l'utilisation de ce stock
on aura on sait ce qui s'est passé dans
d'autres pays européens on sait qu'il y
aura pas assez de de don de de donc
c'est cette question là on va avoir un
jour le la question soit on arrive à
augmenter le nombre de donneurs soit on
va avoir des sujets d'importation euh
parce que c'est vrai que en en Espagne
il y a c'est toutes les pays européens
sont soumis quand même à la directive
européenne he du du don anonyme et
gratuit mais il y a des indemnisation
qui fait qu'il y a plus de dons dans
dans certains voilà c'est le modèle
espagnol il se il est différent
là-dessus aussi donc là il faut qu'on
réfléchisse pour l'instant on est sur
des campagnes d'information qui on a on
vient de faire une nouvelle campagne un
peu atypique où on est on est sur la
logique fait des parents et on explique
bien que c'est pas parce qu'on on donne
son ses gamètres qu' on devient parent
hein c'est même l'acè aux origines c'est
ça ne donne pas un droit de parentalité
hein c'est c'est mais ça permet à des
gens de réaliser leur leur leur soin
donc on a fait un beaucoup de campagnes
là aussi sur les réseaux sociaux pour
chercher des hommes jeunes issus de la
diversité aussi on a toujours ce
problème de d'arriver à trouver aussi
comme pour les CSH hein il faut queon
cherche des hommes jeunes issus de la
diversité on va voir si notre technique
là on a l'air d'avoir des postesses qui
sont assez encourageants mais pas sûr
que ça suffise donc de toute façon cette
question elle va surtout se poser aussi
sur jusqu'où on va après sur
l'importation de de de banques de de
sperme qui existent en Europe euh voilà
qui qui sont aussi une des solutions
mais euh avec c'est ce que c'est ça le
modèle aussi espagnol derrière hein donc
ça je pense qu'il faudra qu'on prenne
quand même le temps de c'est pas
interdit en France he d'importer c'est
déjà possible par que quand vous avez
commencé un parcours d'AMP dans à
l'étranger avec un donneur on quand vous
voulez un deuxième enfant si vous le
faites en France vous pouvez le faire
avec le le même d'onneur donc c'est pas
interdit mais c'est pour l'instant du
cas par cas si on arrive à quelque chose
de plus massif c'est autre chose enfin
voilà donc je pense que ça il faut
réfléchir aussi tu veux peut-être
compléter sur le le le gradient entre la
l'Espagne et la France n'est pas
scientifique hein le niveau de
compétence est le même et souvent les
les gens beaucoup de gens dans les qui
travaill dans les centres espagnols ont
été formés en France le le la la
différence est une différence d'ordre
idéologique hein l'Espagne comme très
souvent s'appuie sur une réflexion
pragmatique qu'est-ce qui marche et et
euh nous on a plutôt une une réflexion
comment euh euh garder la dimension
service public euh très clairement dans
cette dans dans dans cette activité euh
on a sous-estimé euh l'impact sociétal
et notamment la demande on pensait pas
qu'il y aurait huit fois plus de demande
voilà et donc ça dévoile euh une
inadéquation de de la réponse telle
qu'elle a été portée aujourd'hui alors
que les compétences entre le public et
le privé en France sont les mêmes
c'est-à-dire que en France euh c'est des
c'est la gestion qui est publique et
privée mais enfin le financeur est le
même donc et la qualité et la qualité
est comparable donc c'est c'est vraiment
une différence de de conception au
départ à laquelle on peut apporter une
réponse aujourd'hui euh sur la base de
de tout ce qu'on vient de dire
de deux questions à nouveau David pour
Dav merci président d'abord merci pour
cette présentation très dynamique et
didactique et puis merci pour le support
parce que comme tous les bons cours
lorsquon y réfléchit àêre opposé et que
les personnes sont plus là pour que ça
puisse que pour que la greffe puisse
prendre si j'ose dire de ce que vous
avez dit ce sera sera bien utile moi
j'avais deux petites question et puis
une question un peu plus générique les
questions c'est les questions de bécien
je sais pas si ce sera dans les
documents mais moi je intéressé pour
avoir la la répartition de la tendance
en terme de greffe qu'on pense souvent
au transplantation on pense au rein en
tant que béusien mais j'imagine ça a
beaucoup évoluer donc je sais pas si
c'était dans les transparents et la
deuxième question elle est un peu liée à
celle-là aussi vous les avez évoqué les
les difficultés avec notamment les les
salles blocs opératoires et RA pour
pouvoir opérer est-ce que il y a une
cartographie qui est liée à cette
disponibilité où est-ce qu'il y a aussi
des lieux qui sont plus propices à faire
certains types d'opération donc sur le
l'ensemble national est-ce que il y a en
gros une offre de proximité identique ou
est-ce qu' il y a besoin de se déplacer
en fonction de de la de la pathologie et
et du besoin et la question générique
c'est alors on a la chance avec le
président de d'appartenir à la même
commission au Sénat qui travaille
notamment sur les questions de la
recherche et de la simplification de la
recherche donc moi je vois que dans dans
tout ce que vous décrivez vous êtes un
peu la à la croiser des chemins entre à
la fois les avancées technologiques
scientifiques aux avancées attente ou en
tout cas besoins sociétal et donc
législatifs et donc vous êtes souvent
quand vous évoquez les les différents
thèmes c'était passionnant entre le
programme de recherche et les soins
courants c'est TER que vous avez utilisé
dans votes actions est-ce que vous avez
un rôle d'évaluateur à un moment de ceux
qui travaillent sur les programmes de
recherche par rapport ensuite à
la j'ai façon que c'est pas le cas mais
est-ce que en tout cas la question c'est
est-ce que ce serait intéressant qu'il a
une évolution en ce sens qu'on voit que
les sujets vont être de plus en plus
prignants
alors juste sur on vous oui les greffes
rénales restent sur la répartition par
organ ça reste à la majorité c'est 60 %
des greffes on l'a pas mis je vais vous
le rajouter la répartition c'est quand
même le le le gros
besoin voilà c'est c'est oui mais j'is
mis les grfes rénales mais pas la
proportion tu vois des répartitions par
type d'organe j'avais pas mis ça mais en
gros oui c'est clairement la GREF rénale
qui reste le le le en terme de nombre le
plus besoin donc é pu avec une B
pathologie enfin je je vous rappelle he
une prévalence de l'insuffisance rénale
chronique qui augmente avec le diabète
et le surpoids donc en plus c'est des
besoins qui sont croissants c'estd que
c'est pas c'est pas une alors que
paradoxalement par exemple les greffes
pulmonaires qui étaient une petite
partie on il y en a une grosse partie
qui ont se sont arrêtés grâce à des
nouveaux traitements de la mucovicidose
ce qui est quand même génial hein mais
du coup ça il y a une une chute massive
pareil pour avec les traitements de la
de l'hépatite C on a arrêté des
transplantations hépatiques pour ces
cpatites là donc c'est c'est il y a
parfois il y a des chocs tech enfin de
de thérapeutique qui fait que le recours
à la greffe n plus possible mais en tout
cas sur le RIN on n'y est pas et on est
plutôt dans une logique croissante euh
la répartition quand vous me disiez sur
les les sur le territoire en fait non
c'est plutôt bien organisé hein il y a
il y a pas de d'abord c'est une activité
de Chu hein c'est que une activité C
avec des réseaux de prélèvement autour
des ch qui sont qui peuvent être avoir
des prélèvements ont lieu par contre
dans les hôpitaux de proximité aussi euh
mais on a nous même si les autorisations
maintenant sont par région on a nous on
a on a un avis vous savez on a un avis
conforme sur toutes les autorisations
qui sont données donc là on va être dans
la renouvellement des autorisations
parce que les les schémas régionaux ont
été annoncés par toutes les ARS donc on
a on a relu tous les programmes
régionaux les projets régionaux les les
Prs on a donné notre avis parce qu' on
voulait vérifier que tous nos nos plans
étaient bien repris les objectifs
étaient bien repris mais après il y a
pas d'inéquité ça euh je pense pas que
ce soit le sujet c'est
plutôt dans certains hôpitaux ils ont
des tensions en matière de personnel
donc je sais qu' voilà c'est plutôt ça
et donc ça ça c'est variable et c'est et
ça peut choter vite enfin ça peut juste
varier très vite quoi donc ça on est
c'est pour ça qu'on a mis en place les
indicateurs de qualité par équipe et on
a des systèmes d'alerte quand on a on
voit qu'il y a des des des équipes qui
pour et on va voir on a des services
régionaux qui sont très proches de
toutes les équipes et on va les voir
voir comment on peut les appuyer on va
voir les directions on sensibilise
attention là il y a un sujet C je te
laisse peut-être répondre sur la
partieale de la recherche mais on en
fait
juste pour compléter le le le spectre
aujourd'hui des transpantations s'élargi
hein vous savez le en nombre le plus
important c'est les greffes de tissu la
cornée les vaisseaux des la poudre d'os
et cetera et puis à cette cette nouvelle
modalité de transplantation qui sont les
transplantations d'Ilo de langueurance
on on récupère le pancréas on le on le
broie on le on le processe et on injecte
des cellules pancréatiques dans le foie
des patients diabétiques et il
refabriqueent de l'insuline donc on a
fait 80 90 l'année dernière c'est c'est
un changement de c'est un changement
complet de paradigme plutôt que de se
piquer avec de l'insuline c'est réservé
à des patient très sélectionnés donc il
y a un gros travail
là-dessus fa non bien sûr doncôle de
ça c'est oui il y a un contrôle direct
de l'agence sur d'abord c'est c'est nous
qui orientons qui qui mettons en lien
les receveurs et et les donneurs
c'est-à-dire que nous savons qu'il y a
eu un prélèvement de pancréas à Toulouse
et que nous avons sur la liste un
donneur à Lille et donc on transporte le
greffon jusqu'à lîle donc et puis ça
fait 20 ans qu'on qu'on soutient cette
cette activité de recherche qui a été
caractérisé comme des soins courants
c'est-à-dire remboursés par la sécurité
sociale il y a 2 ans donc ça c'est un
continuum et ça fait le lien avec votre
question sur la recherche oui on on ne
contrôle pas mais on contribue on a on
distribue un peu plus d'un million
d'euros de dans des appels d'offre
recherche thématique Greff cellules
procréation génétique et cetera on a un
registre des maladies rénales chronique
qui lui-même fait un appel d'offre
recherche pour les équipes pour la
progression dans la compréhension de
l'évolution de ces maladies
donc on participe grandement à cette
activité
d'évaluationire on éclaire la vie mais
c'est pas nous qui donnons la vie c'est
en nous c'est le ministère c'est le
ministère mais mais on est par exemple
sur les greffes exceptionnelles euh là
les les greffes dont tu as parlé on il y
a un comité pour les greffes
exceptionnelles et on fait partie c'est
nous qui rapportons sur le voilà mais
par contre c'est une décision du
ministère
ça reste des décisions administratives
auxquelles on éclaire voilà et puis on
on fait aussi de la recherche he on
publie environ 80 papiers scientifiques
par an sur c'est de la recherche plus
sur les données que l'on héberge et sur
lesquels on est capable en les
articulant avec le snds qui sont les
données en vie réelle et bien de de
modéliser des choses on a par exemple
des publiclication sur l'impact de la
pauvreté sur sur l'accès au soins ou sur
la prévention et C et donc évidemment si
on devait voir évoluer les mission de de
l'Agence de la biomédecine dans le
domaine de la recherche moi nous serions
ravis de pouvoir devenir un un un acteur
de la recherche pouvoir héberger des des
étudiants comme un Labau de recherche
pour faire de la recherche sur ces
données qui alimentent en fait notre
connaissance de de toute cet écosystème
l'agence est une mine d'or sur les
données enfin moi j'ai découvert ça vu
que depuis un an on a énormément de
bases de données qui sont de très bonnes
rien que le registre rein qui est un un
outil qui est unique au monde hein
d'avoir on a la le suivi exhausif de
tous les personnes dialysées en France
c'est une base de données que le monde
entier nous envit donc on a des des
études extrêmement intéressantes qui
sont faites là-dessus mais on pourrait
encore potentialiser si on avait voilà
une capacité d'accueil de recherche
enfin qui sont là on fait plein de
partenariats avec des équipes ces
données sont mises à disposition enfin
il y a il y a des dans le casre de HES
hub et cetera mais c'est c'est euh je
pense que on peut encore gagner
là-dessus si on facilite les
choses alors il y aura deux dernières
questions je je vais être obligé de de
filer parce que j'ai une autre réunions
à 11h mais il y a Daniel salmont qui
voulait poser une question et puis le
premier vice-président ensuite pi je
vous remercie beaucoup
et merci je vais devoir filer moi aussi
mais une petite question avant vous y
avez déjà partiellement répondu d'abord
merci pour votre exposé vraiment
passionnant et des fois un peu
vertigineux on peut dire surtout dès
qu'on touche à l'intelligence
artificielle euh ma question était sur
la double rupture celle du secret de
l'anonymat pour les dons de gamette bon
vous avez dit que il n'y avait pas eu
d'impact sur la quantité de dons on va
dire par contre est-ce qu'il y a eu des
études sociologiques sur l'impact aussi
bien du donneur que en quelque sorte
receveur sur cette rupture secret et
anonyma alors actuellement euh ils sont
on d'abord les enfant c'est les enfants
qui ont je vous rappelle c'est les
enfants né du don qui pourront demander
la levée d'anonyat donc ceux dans le
cadre de la nouvelle loi ils sont ils
commencent tout juste à être conçus donc
là il y a ils nont pas encore demandé
euh mais par contre on a mis en place
vous savez une commission une la capade
qui permet pour les enfants qui sont
déjà nés pour dans l'ancien régime où on
va rechercher donc là il y a eu des il y
a eu à peu près 300 demande de de
personnes donc on est un peu dans
récupérer le stock ce qui est pas énorme
hein parce que je crois que 50000
enfants qui sont nés d'un d'un d'un don
donc c'est c'est tout voilà c'est une
très faible proportion et on a retrouver
à peu près les les les donneurs dans la
moitié des cas et il y a en gros un/3
qui ont accepté de donner leur leur
accord pour donc là on est ça commence
tout juste donc on n pas encore de c'est
vraiment ça se compte sur les doigts
d'une main on n pas encore une m
suffisante de de de personnes pour faire
une étude voir qu'est-ce que ça donne et
cetera donc euh on verra c'est un sujet
hein c'est un sujet auquel on a débattu
on a reçu la présidente de la capade
pour en parler avec nous mais je pense
que c'est on voit déjà qu'en terme de
quantité c'est assez faible enfin c'est
pas une c'est pas voilà tant mieux c'est
et après je je pense que de toute façon
ça donnera des réponses mais c'est pas
sûr que c'est des impacts si forts que
ça en
fait donc on verra pour l'instant on
n'est pas encore on est un petit
décalage dans le temps c'est c'est moins
une c'est moins une rupture de
l'anonymat qu' qu'uneib pour les enfants
n d' d'accéder à leurs origines
oui ma remarque ma première remarque
d'abordorté effectivement sur également
cette même interrogation c'est vrai que
vous évoquez tout à l'heure l'exemple de
la greffe duutérus
mfille qui remettait potentiellement en
cause le principe d'anonymat mais on
comprend effectivement aussi le sur le
don du vivant il y a pas
d'anonymat quand vous faites un don du
vivant vous êtes vous avez une greffe
rénal vous avez besoin de on va vous
dire c'est c'est le seul cas où il y a
enfin quand c'est en intrafamilial où
vous savez maintenant c'est voilà les
amis proches il y a si vous êtes
compatible quand vous donnez votre drain
à votre frère par définition il y a pas
non plus d'anonymat donc c'est c'est
c'est pas la première le premier cas
voilà c'est c'est le don du vivant c'est
c'est prévu par la loi il a voilà et et
et simplement peut-être une une question
un peu d'anticipation vous évoquz tout à
l'heure notamment toutes les évolutions
concernant les les cellules souches
embryonnaires et notamment d'avancé de
recherche qui qui pourrai être faite à
l'avenir est-ce qu'on pourrait pas
penser dès maintenant à une conservation
de ces cellules souches embryonnaires
pour chaque individu pour qu'elle puisse
l'accompagner tout au long de sa vie et
pourquoi pas 80 ans après sa naissance
que ça puisse bénéficier à l'individu en
en
personne alors il y a déjà une réponse
de ce type là dans beaucoup de pays hein
qui est une réponse comm commercial
c'està-dire je je garde je prends un peu
du sent de cordon de votre bébé je le
garde parce que si un jour il a une
leucémie on pourra récupérer le le la
difficulté de ça c'est le la qualité et
et les conditions dans lesquelles c'est
gardé il y a eu les premières faillites
de ces banques qui ont donc qui ont
éteint les congélateurs et donc qui ont
tout perdu et je je à ce jour c'est pas
la meilleure façon de répondre au
besoins de santé publique c'est-à-dire
que le le le risque d'avoir besoin de
ses propres cellules à un moment donné
dans sa vie et infime par rapport à ce
que ça va générer en terme
organisationnel de coûte et cetera de
santé publique de de conserver les les
cellules de chacun il est pas dit que ce
sera pas fait à l'avenir mais il a pas
dit non plus à l'avenir qu'on sera pas
en mesure d'avoir une banque de cellules
souche un peu comme ce dont on disait
pour que chacun puisse bénéficier d'un
accès à ces thérapeutique même si c'est
pas la vôtre c'est c'est pas forcément
ouis aujourd'hui euh le le le banking
perso c'est c'est un c'est un peu une
c'est un peu joué sur la corde sensible
des des des jeunes parents qui ont les
moyens de de financer ça et ça ça répond
pas vraiment à un besoin de santé
publique
oui
ouais des perspectives thérapeutiques
bon formidables euh on sait pas jusquoù
on ira euh mais moi si je prends
l'exemple en cancérologie on base
maintenant de plus en plus
euh les la la protection d'individus sur
la prévention euh avec des problèmes bon
qu'on connaît de manque de spécialistes
mais ça c'est pas le à l'ordre du jour
euh l'établissement de de ces
prédiagnostics et de profils
génétiques risque de poser un problème
et de nous amemmener nous aussi
législateur je crois à intervenir comme
on l'a fait à une époque qu'avec le le
droit à l'oubli parce que quand quand on
connaît la porosité de nos systèmes de
sécurité on a vu que les G femes arrivé
à établir des profil thérapeutique à
partir de croisement de de plusieurs
données je pense qu'il faudra qu'on se
repenche sur le ce problème d'éthique
par rapport aux compagnies d'assurance
qui auront accès d'une façon ou d'une
autre à ces à ces profils et là ça va
poser je crois un réel problème parce
que sûr puis après il y a un risque
enfin sans il y a y a les compagnies
d'assurces ça c'est dans le domaine on
va dire civil mais même après sur le
domaine de l'intérieur on pouvez dire si
on commence à à dire bah tiens il y a
tel profil de personnes qui sont à
risque de je dis pas de délinquence ou
de ou de faire c enfin on peut avoir
après des des manière de ficher les gens
sans avoir avec des des risques de
dérive
d'utilisation voilà à des fins en terme
de liberté individuelle qui peuvent
avoir des des effets très graves he
enfin donc il faut qu'on soit c'est pour
d'où l'intérêt de qui conserve nos
données d'où ça rejoint ce que je vous
disais sur les tests génétiques hein
quand les gens envoient leur données il
ils se ils se rendent pas compte aussi
de ce qu'ils peuvent générer contre eux
et contre leur famille enfin à terme
dans dans un contexte malveillant enfin
la période la situation géopolitique
actuelle nous montre bien que ça peut
vite dérappé dans un sens ou dans
l'autre et donc il faut quand même faire
enfin voilà faut être d'une
prudence très forte sur ces sujets là
oui bah en tout cas il y a même enfin
après c'est aussi au niveau européen il
faut que ce soit voilà parce que c'est
derrière ça dépasse les données
dépassent nos frontières quoi donc faut
avoir une réflexion déjà au niveau
française puis après évidment l'exporter
pour que ce soit aussi appliqué ailleurs
quoi très bien mais écoutez un grand
merci à vous et on vous envoie dans la
journée le petit document
voilà fait 45 pages voilà c'est ça merci
à vous
lev